For the first time in more than 60 years, China's population has fallen.
This could indicate the possible start of a long-term decline.
Beijing's National Bureau of Statistics said...
…the population decreased by 850,000 people to 1.4 billion.
The country also reported its lowest birth rate since official records began...
…and its highest death rate in decades.
China's one child policy ended in 2015...
…but despite various incentives offered by the government...
…the growth rate has continued to fall.
Our reporter, Katie Silva, is following developments in Singapore.
Hi, Katie, good to see you.
I mean, these are really significant figures, aren't they?
They are.
So, you wouldn't think a country with a population of 1.4 billion...
…would be concerned about having a few less,...
…but as you mentioned, 850,000 fewer from the end of 2021 to the end of 2022...
…if we look backwards one year.
And the reason that they are concerned by this...
...is many say this is a population time bomb...
…that it is ushering in a period of decline.
And this is likely to be a trend and these numbers dropping are likely to continue.
Now, as you mentioned the death and birth rate were also the lowest in years,...
…and many are saying as well that with China giving up its zero COVID policy,...
…the increase in spike in cases and the problems when it comes to hospitalizations,...
…that's going to do nothing to try and help alleviate this burden...
…when it comes to the death rate.
Now, many hospitals there as I mentioned, overwhelmed.
We've been hearing as well from the commissioner of the National Bureau of Statistics.
He's given something more of an outline about exactly what the numbers are telling us.